اخر ابو داوود
الاخر اذا صاروخان يبدو انهما في منطقه
قريبه منا فوقنا تحديدا
يبدو انهما في مدى بعيد اطلق بالفعل يبدو
واضح من ان الاستهداف
يبدو ان الاستهداف طبعا في طبقات الجو
العليا
وهذا يعني بان مدى الاطلاق هو بعيد ليس
فقط في منطقه الغلاف
سنرى اين ربما المعلومات المتوفره الى اين
وصل هذان الصاروخان لكن واضح بانهما
اطلقاه في مدن بعيد في طبقات الجو العليا
وهذا يرجح ان يكون على الاقل استهدفاه
ربما منطقه اسدود او عسقلان تحديدا
المناطق الشماليه منها من المدينه
لا يوجد اعتراض من فوقنا سوى اننا شاهدنا
الصاروخان
ليس واضحا يبدو ان الاعتراض سيكون في
منطقه بعيده عنه وهذا يعني بان هذان
الصاروخان اطلق نعم وكما توقعت بالفعل
هنالك الان في منطقه رماديان اي تل ابيب
نتحدث ربما عن استهداف لمنطقه تل ابيب
الان
نعم نعم كما يبدو كذلك بالفعل المنطقه
الان في المستهدفه هي منطقه
تل ابيب تل ابيب من الناحيه الشرقيه اي
ربما المطار المطار المدني مطار بن غوريون
الدولي كما توقعت بالفعل الصاروخان لم يتم
اعتراضهما من فوقنا
كما يسيران في مدى مرتفع
الان ذوي صافرات الانذار في منطقه جوشدان
اي منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى نعم الان نشاهد
ايضا سقوط ربما لصاروخ من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في منطقه مفتوحه قريبه منا ان
تشاهدون اشتعال النيران في هذه الحقول
المفتوحه الى الشمال تقريبا او الى الشرق
اكثر من مدينه ازديروت اذا كما توقعنا
الان الصاروخان الذي رصدناهما من فوقنا
وكنا يسيران في طبقات الجو العليا ولم يتم
اعتراضهما من فوقنا من القبه الحديديه
توقعنا انهما باتجاه منطقه تل ابيب بالفعل
والان صافرات الانذار تدوي في مدينه تل
ابيب الكبرى في منطقه رمادجان